what's up everybody
so Avengers four is being pushed up a
little bit but it's not as simple as
we're changing the date and this is the
new date now for starters the date is
still the same for the u.s. the only
thing that has changed is the IMAX dates
it's a little odd that the only dates
that have changed in the u.s. are the
IMAX dates but as of right now that is
what it is the IMAX dates worldwide have
been pushed up to late April
but again in the u.s. anything that is
not IMAX has the same release date as
before May 3rd but in the UK the date
has moved not just for IMAX but for all
theaters the date has moved to April
26th in the UK and according to a report
from IMDB they're not even going to be
the first ones to get it it'll actually
premiere on April 24th in France
followed by premiering in Germany on
April 25th so it's a little all over the
place right now I don't think this will
stick I think eventually they will
either end up moving all of the dates
IMAX and normal viewings to late April
or they will keep it the same because
you have to realize that there are a lot
of places in all parts of the world that
don't really have IMAX theaters so in my
mind it's kind of like are you really
going to let just certain parts of the
world see it a whole week before it
comes out especially when everybody at
Marvel Studios knows how our online
community is everything about the movie
will be leaked the day it comes out and
they know this and that's why I think
that it'll probably be changed to where
all of the dates are the same unless we
have a situation like we currently have
with ant-man and the wasp where it's
currently only just coming out this week
in certain countries but let's hope that
that really doesn't happen one thing to
note that is kind of funny is that
Shazam comes out in April so
yeah not sure if that's intentional but
either way good luck Shazam so just
wanted to do this video so everybody can
stay up to date on what is currently
happening with these release dates let
me know what you think is going on here
in the comments below and we are still
doing our giveaway of course giving away
a few copies of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray all you have to do to enter is
be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero thank you so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you